moment of the sexual experience we'll
ask the young lady who's your daddy this
should be remixed if officer akeemov is
watching
this could be the next remix masterpiece
dude because just wait till you see what
happens here oh officer officer akimov
is here uh that's beautiful
who's your dad i'm joined today by
pastor james david manning
[Music]
i'm joined today by pastor james david
manning
[Music]
is the most successful pimp on planet
earth to reverence the word of god to
trust it to preach it to teach it
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
[Music]
george bush
and george bush jr have been penetrated
by at least 100 men in their anus a
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
strong i didn't do it that's not my
problem oh i got down on my knees
i didn't do it but i was tempted
sounds like quite an evening
[Music]
and loads of money and tons and tons of
lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
let me say something to you about
marketing
[Music]
starbucks has done the exact same thing
that coca-cola has done except they've
done it with
that certainly seems to be a story that
has been missed
[Music]
each other's semen how do you know that
it flavors the coffee gays tend to love
each other's semen
[Music]
each other's semen how do you know that
it flavors the coffee gays tend to love
each other's semen
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
lows and loads of money and tons and
tons of live
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of live
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow what an introduction couldn't
possibly start uh any more strongly
today
what a crazy day
my plan was to stream the white house
press briefing with jen saki the white
house press secretary that's coming up
at the bottom of the hour or in the next
five hours sometimes they're as much as
five hours late it's it's actually crazy
um
and there have been increasingly tense
exchanges between gen saki and reporters
like emerald robinson from newsmax and
presumably there will be questions as a
result of
yesterday's joe biden town hall which i
was live for etc etc that was the
original plan
then alec baldwin accidentally shot
someone to death
um it's one of the most insane stories
and we've got a bunch of different
articles
with a prop gun and we'll talk about
what is it even i tweeted about this
what does it mean that it's a prop gun
and there are different
news elements we're going to look at an
updated report from the associated press
it it's it's a just a crazy story
in addition to that
um we now have been told that yes
the
remains of brian laundry have also been
found and so now
if he killed gabby petito then he did he
then take his own life
or
were the circumstances of his death
different and that that's another story
that now is going on and a number of
different reports about that we're also
uh following live coverage of the alec
baldwin situation
let's just listen to a few minutes of
what's going on on nbc news here we're
going to get to super chats we have
voice mails
a lot happening says
they support them and at this time they
don't know if charges will be filed but
they will look into the facts and
evidence as the case progresses with
great discretion so very little details
are being shared uh for now as we wait
uh for authorities to continue with this
investigation all right guadabanegas for
us their quad thank you let's go ahead
and bring in nbc news legal analyst
danny cevallos you know danny you have
had experiences in cases like this i
mean this is a movie set there are rules
for how you use firearms what have you
seen in your experience that tells you
about who might actually be facing
liability here right
safety is supposed to be one of the most
important uh missions on a film set
typically you have a first assistant
director who holds a safety meeting and
if you have firearms there's someone
called an armorer or a master of weapons
who not only checks all the weapons but
shows the actors how to use them and
then of course if it's a stunts you have
a stunt coordinator who should also be
checking uh the firearms and really any
stunts that are supposed to be going on
i mean arguably the actor has the least
responsibility the actors there to act
and the actor trusts that the people in
the crew will hand him something right
that is safe to use it's interesting
that you say the actor should actually
you know in an ideal world be the one
with the least responsibility because
he's being handed things that have been
deemed safe so what about alec baldwin i
mean what what could potentially be next
for him
from his tweet he's cooperating with law
enforcement but some initial reports
have him saying you know i've never been
given a hot gun a hot gun meaning a
loaded gun and there's a fundamental
rule on sets that you should never ever
ever have live rounds yeah it's so so as
you can tell there's so many obvious
questions here that we just don't have
answers to so let's go through the
reports sort of in order
so
um
iatsc says alec baldwin rust prop gun
had live round cops say that hasn't yet
been determined law enforcement don't
know right now if the prop gun
that alec baldwin fatally fired on a new
mexico film set contained a live single
round despite claims from an la iatsi
local we haven't even begun the
forensics on that issue that hasn't been
determined by us as of yet we expect to
have more information next week
the story is cinematographer helena
hutchins was killed by the weapon rust
star producer baldwin discharged on
thursday on location
director joel souza was injured too and
taken to a local hospital he has since
been released baldwin was questioned by
police and released no arrests or
charges have been filed
the sheriff's department said late last
night as details were emerging ayatse
local 44 sent out an email to members
alleging there were more than blanks in
the prop gun dear members as many of us
have heard there was an accidental
weapons discharge on a production titled
rust being filmed in new mexico a live
single round
was accidentally fired on set
by the principal actor alec baldwin
hitting both the director of photography
local 600 member helena hutchins and
director joel souza both were rushed to
the hospital we lost sister hudgens who
passed from the wound
local 44 has confirmed that the prop set
decoration special effects and
construction departments were staffed by
new mexico crew members there were no
local 44 members on the call sheet
thoughts and prayers go out etc the
union believes a live single round in
the prop gun because of the amount of
damage the bloc the blast caused to
hutchins and to souza who supposedly was
standing behind the director of
photography when the shot struck her
so then
sheriff's office alec baldwin discharged
a prop gun that killed a crew member now
if it's a prop gun with a live round and
you shoot someone with the round
it's not really a what is the prop l i
mean it's not really a prop gun anymore
right and this is this is the confusion
and i got some informed tweets in
response which we'll look at in a moment
actor alec baldwin discharged a prop
firearm
thursday on a movie set south of santa
fe killing the director of photography
for the film he was working on wounding
its director
baldwin could be seen outside the
sheriff's office headquarters distraught
and in tears while on the phone no
charges filed according to a news
release
latest update from the
associated press 36 minutes ago alec
baldwin fired a prop gun on set killing
cinematographer
actor alec baldwin fired a prop gun on
the set of a western and killed the
cinematographer the director was wounded
helena hutchins cinematographer and
director joel souza were shot
spokesperson for baldwin said there was
an accident involving the misfire of a
prop gun with blanks
sam so
again was it um you were all you see the
conflict it was a prop gun with blanks
that misfired which what i'm told can
happen is if you're really close to
someone you can do damage with the blank
the other is no there was actually a
live round
which means it's no longer really a prop
gun
it was not clear if baldwin was
performing at the time of the shooting
or how many rounds were fired and little
was known about the weapon
friday baldwin tweeted expressing
condolences calling it an accident there
are no words to convey my shock and
sadness regarding the tragic accident
that took the life of helena hutchins a
wife mother and deeply admired colleague
of ours i'm fully cooperating with the
police my heart is broken for her
husband their son and all who knew and
loved so
it's
this is a tragedy
uh prop guns fire blanks gun powder
charges that produce a flash and a bang
but not a hard projectile
when the trigger is pulled the paper
plastic wadding is ejected from the
barrel with enough force that it can be
lethal at close range as proved to be
the case in the death of an actor in
1984.
um in another onset accident in 93 the
actor brandon lee was killed after a
bullet was left in a prop gun see this
is the part that's the aspect of
confusion
if it's a prop gun and it's just
supposed to have blanks then how does a
bullet get left in it
why would there be a bullet at all why
are their bullets even on set right
that's the question that is being
explored right now
and um i tweeted this morning before
there was much information about it and
a lot of the responses
had a you know a real gun was used as a
prop
um
if it fires a blank it can still be
deadly at short range blanks can kill if
fired at close range it'd happen to
bruce lee's son brandon
but then there's also the question of
was there a live round which is also
being reported they probably switched
the bullets i've heard they sometimes do
that i don't know why blanks fire with
normal force anything in the barrel will
be expelled at dangerous speeds blanks
are crimped closed and have kind of
wadding to hold the powder in place the
crimping can break blanks still produce
an explosion that's logical
if the story of there was a live round
isn't true
all of the blank stuff becomes
irrelevant if there was a live round so
um
it's just it's early
and it does seem that the legal
consensus is if alec baldwin has just
handed this thing and knows nothing
about it
it's it's hard to imagine
that he would be legally liable but
i emotionally i can't even imagine what
that uh what what that has to be like so
we're going to continue to stand by
for additional information there
a lot of people saying well it's clearly
manslaughter but but is it even is it
even
alec baldwin manslaughter is the
question
it's a crazy situation and i don't know
that we're gonna learn everything about
it
today necessarily but we do have a bunch
of different things to look at
a few super chats coming in do i think
steve bannon will get arrested um
no i don't
guess alec felt too guilty calling crew
member a rude little pig so he shot him
yeah i mean you know i
okay
all right who let dick cheney on the set
right
right
uh
wow crazy situation crazy situation
i do want to say thanks to some folks
that are here
and um
have been supporting the stream
those include
as we get ready for the press briefing
those include half cabbage billy
carpenter
odw
crystal drama free
fifth dimension
tricia north star and the teal appeal
putting us at seven
we do have a new coupon code today
the coupon code is sinks and showers and
it saves you 69 you might be wondering
sinks and showers what does that mean
and this is the reference we're looking
very strongly at sinks and showers so
that's the reference today's coupon code
uh oh wait a second what
what's going on here with that oh i see
okay i see what's going on yeah that's
the reference 69 discount and we will we
will open phone lines today
if we get to 100 website members and
twitch subs you can sign up at
joinpacman.com i would love it if you
did i really would it's it's uh
uh it's our number one funding source
and you get an extra show every day and
by the way sinks and showers hard to
come up with a better coupon code than
that a first person to use it for oh
here's a here's an extra first person to
use the coupon code sinks and showers
counts as five on our quest to a hundred
first person counts as five five x
all right okay i have one unban request
here to adjudicate
um if you are unlucky enough or
too so moronic that you get banned on
twitch you can ask to be unbanned
this is a user named joe's lip
who um
wow really a toxic presence
why is this guy covering this
referring to something i covered at some
point
nazi's bribed jews into getting
vaccinations
biden dementia
boomer bait
dollar store streamer dave packman god
how i miss trump
they were banned
just you know negative presence
then their unban request is sorry i
called you a dollar store streamer i'll
be silent from now on well if you don't
plan on chatting even if unbanned you
don't need to be unbanned that is a
perma
just just not a presence we need here
okay
so
that's an easy one easy one to
adjudicate there
we'll close that out
good
um a couple other questions coming in
via super chat why shooting at the crew
anyway negligent regardless yeah we we
just don't know enough about the
circumstances yet to be able to say much
for sure
we just don't uh we just don't know
what does it mean that it will count
five times okay let me see
let me see if i can explain this to you
okay
normally when one person
signs up on my website
the number here goes up by one so like
for example if one person signed up it
would go from seven to eight
if one person then signed up again it
would go from eight to nine by five x i
mean that the first person to use the
coupon code sinks and showers we're
looking very strongly at sinks and
showers it would instead of going from
seven to eight it would go from seven to
twelve
are we on the same page here are we on
the same page okay good
excellent excellent that's at
joinpakman.com
also want to say thanks to dollar
batteries
sweet thang kay gouldy
moogy lover
d4 ray wow i'm really struggling with
some of these that puts us at 12 because
that's actually five
um
yeah okay good all right let's look at a
couple of different things i've got here
uh here you know we've been talking
about
why is it that all of these fox hosts
constantly denounce vaccine mandates
without mentioning fox news has one of
the strictest vaccine mandates of any
company it was finally addressed on fox
and friends this morning
and here's here's how they are now
addressing it after you missed
information he said about fox he thought
it was says i think it's funny that fox
has a vaccine mandate you have a testing
option at fox so what he said is totally
inaccurate we don't have joe biden also
offers a vaccine a testing option a
mandate we have a protocol right
oh wow
it's not a mandate there it's a protocol
apply
light and heat to cure maybe you can
maybe you can't i'm not a doctor right
um this this is this is horseshit okay
so the biden
mandate is
vaccinate
or test weekly
the fox mandate is vaccinate or test
daily
right
how can you say that vaccinate or test
weekly is a mandate but vaccinate or
test daily is a protocol
and by the way as far as we knew it fox
if you're in that unvaccinated and
testing daily category you've also still
got to be wearing a mask
it's just utter horseshit
um
insane
insane but i mean listen it seems like
their audience is the one that would
fall for something like that
um
okay i want to say thank you to claudius
hein or heine
who is the first person ever to sign up
on my website with the coupon code sinks
and showers and that counts 5x already
putting us at 17.
sinks and showers is today's new coupon
code also thank you to jessica solansky
for using that same code
and tyler moore using the same code
putting us already at 19. we're looking
very strongly at sinks and showers
elements of bathrooms right
i very much appreciate that uh and the
code is the i actually am shocked at how
well the code is working people asking
why 69
off if we did 70 off it could violate
federal coupon code statues not statutes
statues and then we'd have to pull the
statues down
by keeping it below 70 at 69 percent
it's sort of like if you have a car
that's faster than 10 seconds you need a
roll cage when you drag race it if the
coupon code goes above 69 percent we are
in violation of a whole bunch of
different statues
and so it's it's just a loophole
bw rock says david i thought biden's
town hall was a mess last night do you
think he should do any more try a
different forum to sell priorities yeah
it it people are already furious with me
and a lot of them honestly i had two
this is this actually is depressing i
joke about this but it genuinely makes
me really really bummed out two people
canceled their paid memberships to my
website last night because i didn't give
a glowing review of joe biden's town
hall and my review was the first segment
was pretty good
the second segment was so so and the
third and fourth segments were
bad
like in the third and fourth segment
there were two stories that literally
went nowhere and he even seemed confused
about what the original point of the
story was and then when he said i guess
i should go to the border it was obvious
that that was gonna be seized on i just
was looking at newsmax minutes ago and
they were actually talking about just
just unforced errors
and
two people wrote to me and said david
i'm pulling my two bucks a month
because of that
it's just depressing it's like do i do
first of all do we need to even agree on
everything right could we maybe disagree
on a few things and you still think it's
valuable to support this show
okay you know i guess maybe not but then
also it's it was such a mild criticism
like it started really good and he was
doing substance and stuff and then it
was not so good whoa like
come on guys it's uh
you know it's it's it's depressing but
thankfully some other people are signing
up today i want to say thanks to brahm
von zeeland bram von zeeland for signing
up using the coupon code sinks and
showers very strongly it sinks and
showers also thank you to alessandra
veliz who just signed up using that same
coupon code saving 69 at joinpakman.com
uh okay good
um
matthew asks is it like when that last
coupon code violated our hippo rights
you know actually we got into a real
problem we once did a coupon code it
violated everybody's owl rights eagle
and salamander and we had it was just
lawsuits massive massive dumps of
lawsuits raining down they call them
dumps
um daniel says
cephecephalide yeah i do have that here
cephei
seferheide
did you see jd vance's vile tweet about
alec baldwin i didn't let's see jd vance
twitter
let's see what he had to say vance is
disgusting
um
dear jack let trump back on we need alec
baldwin tweets is that the tweet you're
referring to
wow
christian yeah
um
it seems like that was the only one
yeah it's like i enjoyed his book
hillbilly elegy i really did
but then he he's just so vile
so so vile people asking about the vod
of the town hall we pulled it because of
a copyright risk we were advised uh on
the advice of council to avoid
copyright issues we did the live stream
but then we pulled the archive so just
just to be safe uh cnn is very very
litigious so that's the reason for that
is biden aware of gabby potito's murder
i believe he is
i i have no reason to think that he's
not but yeah
i want to say thanks to william smith
william smith just signed up at
joinedpakman.com using the coupon code
sinks and showers very much appreciate
that william
johnny minogue says thanks for the very
strong podcasting advice from this
week's town hall when will the next
pacman live town hall be i don't know
i don't know yeah i remember johnny from
boston we spoke about podcasting um i
don't know when we are scheduling the
next one maybe uh maybe soon i also want
to say thanks to aaron kausman who just
signed up on my website using the coupon
code sinks and showers we're looking
very strongly at sinks and showers let's
look at a couple of other things that
i've got
um
oh yeah this is funny oh this is so
funny uh congressman ken buck
skips over trump and mentions obama's
golfing this is like you you can't
it's beyond parody take a look at this
remember trump golfed one out of every
five days in office but there we are i
mean that's that's where we are with
this stuff now we talked about president
biden heading to delaware again this
weekend and you heard him say before you
know i don't have time to go to the
border i've just been too busy going to
hurricanes and all these natural
disasters and all the other
issues that i haven't been able to
address but i mean i think that rings
hollow for you sir and for a lot of
people in this country when they see the
images of what's happening down there
this guy has time to meet with
influencers social media influencers at
the white house
child music stars all this other stuff
but no time for the border come on
well it's not just that it's such a
stark contrast between
president trump who was an energizer
bunny he was everywhere all the time and
uh on every golf course you mean
meetings and and really uh unbelievable
work ethic and energy
and then you've got president biden who
uh on weekends is
staying in delaware uh it sort of
reminds you of the number of golf games
that president obama had but trump
golfed one out of every five days that
he was in office
and he goes yeah biden's so lazy he's
almost like obama with the golfing what
about trump's record golfing they don't
care delusional they were pathetic okay
next martha blackburn
seems confused about how communicable
disease works
a stuart varney by the way has developed
his own sort of confused tucker
carlson-like face himself seeking to do
and what my legislation
will do is anyone that was deemed an
essential worker during the pandemic
showed up did their job
they have earned the right
to be exempted from this vaccine because
they figured out how to protect
themselves actually a lot of those
people got sick
how stupid is that comment
think about what she's saying she's
saying listen
a lot of these essential workers and by
that she's talking about people at
retail restaurants etc
these essential workers worked through
the pandemic before we even had a
vaccine so they should definitely be
exempt from any vaccine requirements
today
a ton of them got sick i was speaking to
a cashier at my local grocery store the
other day
and she said oh
it wasn't being publicized but people
were getting sick all day people were
getting coveted all the time when we
were open before the vaccines were out
is it what how is that even what
how is that even how is that even an
explanation it's a bizarre she seems to
just not understand how viruses work
uh oh hold on is this starting oh no not
yet let's turn the volume up so we don't
miss it
just so dumb so so dumb
uh
thanks to xerocool for supporting via
twitch prime your new member number 24
today
let's see what else we've got i had a
bunch of other things ready to go here
oh yeah why is this news right here
ex espn or allison williams i walked
away from largest contract of career
over the vaccine mandate
you didn't like the requirements to have
a certain job so you turned it down
how's that news
former espn reporter alison williams who
left the company after refusing to get
vaccinated said she walked away from the
largest contract in my career
it was contingent on me getting an
injection which i was morally ethically
and medically opposed to
so when it came down to it i knew i
couldn't get it how is that news it's
not new
sometimes people don't like the work
schedule
sometimes people don't like the fact
that they need other vaccines to go to a
job
but this is news now apparently let's
take a look at this
[Music]
did espn say anything to you about
the fact that your doctor was backing
you about the fact that you you do have
natural immunity
no
um no and i ultimately requested a
religious accommodation um and i think
this is
yeah they didn't go for my medical
excuse so then i just said it's my
religion and they still said no
an interesting part of the dynamic um
that i wasn't sure i wanted to share but
so my doctor in my conversation agreed
with me supported me um i have
a belief that doctors are
people you work with in health they
don't tell you what to do they suggest
it's just like who cares who cares so
you didn't you turned the job down okay
you should do and they work with you to
find the best um decisions for your
health i don't think they should be
dictators and i think they they give
their opinions right and you weigh that
with your own so in my conversations
with my doctors i expressed my concerns
he understood them he supported them he
said absolutely whatever you need uh
from a medical exemption support wise we
will we will do for you i 100 support
agree with your decision not to get this
vaccine it's a very little benefit for
someone like you and i can't tell you
with 100 certainty that this is going to
cause absolutely no issues
so he supported me
but what's very interesting is i live in
california and this state has made it
very very difficult for medical
professionals to write exemptions for
masks or for vaccines they've actually
made it very difficult for anyone to get
a religious exemption which i think is
great
and they put a lot of pressure on our
doctors and when i reached out to follow
up with my doctor's assistant to request
the information needed for my medical
exemption she said let me get back to
you
we're going to have a meeting as an
office and determine how we want to go
forward with this because there are so
many
women requesting this wow and they
ultimately decided as a clinic that they
would not write any exemptions
it's like
okay so why how is that even
dramatic i was heartbroken i'd already
started the process of applying for a
medical exemption with espn and i was
told i would be supported i brought this
up they said we're sorry we just can't
as a company
as a clinic subject ourselves to the
scrutiny that essentially will come with
writing these exemptions so do do you
see what they're doing to people they're
essentially taking away what they
believe is best for you because of the
bureaucracy and the pressure that
happens when you involve politics in
medicine and this is a really dangerous
space to occupy and it scares me
that people are not only supporting this
but encouraging it medical decisions
need to be for individuals not for for
the population in mass
they are in other words if any job there
are jobs where it's like hey you know
what you're going to be working in a
country where x is rampant and so if you
want to go you're going to have to get
vaccinated
and you might be like oh i don't want
the job then oh okay well then you don't
have to get vaccinated just don't
don't take the job right
we just had david zweig a journalist
who's been doing great work on covid and
the mask mandates and so on on yesterday
wrote a great piece in new york magazine
and and follow-ups and he was saying
prior to joining us yesterday he was on
the phone with doctors and respect i'm
getting i'm just i'm sick of this uh
it's like okay so these are private
companies and it's not illegal for them
to require a vaccine so are you
suggesting new regulation of private
companies because you get you guys are
usually against regulating these
companies
it's uh it's
essential oils book in the background
says enough oh i didn't see that oh hold
on a second
uh oh i i regret closing it out now
uh how do i how can i find that again
megan kelly espn oh wait hold on new oh
no i know where it is i know where it is
it's because i tweeted about it
here it is
a set there was an if there's an
essential oils book in the back or that
i have to say
let's see where was it
oh my god yeah there is look at this
right there essential oils yeah okay so
listen she doesn't want the vaccine but
she's got an essential oils book yeah
that like we could have skipped thank
you we could have skipped the entire
segment and just i could have been like
here's someone who's making a big deal
out of quitting over the vaccine who has
a book about essential oils and then
that we we would have just been able to
skip over all of it i apologize for
wasting everybody's time uh okay
i uh i
good that's good so we're standing by
here for
gen saki we are also monitoring um oh by
the way did you guys see this
and calling out to the quote water
goddess
because obviously this is ridiculous
we think of native people as existing in
these primitive past tense stereotypes
elizabeth ellis is a native woman and
history professor at new york university
and if you are expecting native people
to be running around in leather and
feathers it's hard to think of them in
the contemporary moment and this
actually really limits our access to
political power and to be taken
seriously as native people neither the
teacher nor the school where the
incident allegedly occurred responded
allegedly his request for comment this
might not have occurred posted online
the riverside unified school district
said quote these behaviors are
completely unacceptable and an offensive
depiction of the vast and expansive
native american cultures and practices
the district says the teacher has been
placed on leave as they conduct a full
investigation i hope that they do some
re-educating and that they make sure
that something like this never happens
again yeah that was wild
um
yeah
so we're so we're we're monitoring the
uh the the
alec baldwin situation and then we're
also standing by for gen saki we're
keeping an eye on what's being reported
on newsmax apparently you can get
fruit and vegetable capsules there
balance of nature
let's just see what that is
balanceofnature.com what what's up with
that
you need more fruits and vegetables
balance of nature can help
okay
how it's made see how we pack 10
servings of fruits
and veggies into six
capsules that seems
not possible
recipe to break up the blah
health coaching
fruit veggies let's take a look at what
this is
100 all natural whole food supplement
okay all natural not a regulated term no
gmo
meaningless
no gluten well they're fruits and
vegetables
sugars artificial sweeteners synthetics
okay fruits a blend of 16 fruits
take three capsules daily
so it's basically a month supply
it tastes great because it's 100 produce
some people chew the fruits as a treat
you can also swallow them with water
our fruit blend swallow them with water
very very large a brain big water ocean
water yeah
ingredients aloe vera
apple banana blueberry cherry cranberry
grape grapefruit lemon mango
is weird
like what is it it's
it's 10 calories but it has 10 fruits in
it that doesn't really make sense
the maintain blend
repair blend
it's funny it's actually hard to figure
out what this is
take three capsules
you can open them and sprinkle them on a
salad
what
what a bizarre product quite frankly
fiber and spice whole health system
let's see what this one has
a bread blend of 16 fruits
a blend of 15 vegetables
fiber and spice
well all right you can get that i guess
on on newsmax
just kind of strange very very weird
um
okay
thanks to the freak
for re-upping their twitch subscription
now 19 months in a row the freak coming
in with a message the message is hello
sir i don't even know what i'm doing sir
19 beautiful months
thank you david thank you
on your new member number 25 today i
want to remind everybody we do have a
one day only coupon code the coupon code
is sinks and showers we're looking very
strongly at sinks and showers and it
saves you 69
on my website uh often imitated never
equaled our coupon codes
um and i really appreciate everybody who
signed up so far today on my website
aaron william alessandra
brahm
tyler
jessica
claudius a lot of great people a lot of
really really great people
um okay
b lee was killed by a live round left in
the gun yes
baldwin is also a producer of russ so he
could be held responsible due to that
we have no idea
on the alec baldwin stuff
what sort of uh legal implications there
are alec baldwin speaks out okay let's
see
there are no words he says
uh there are no words okay we saw that
yeah
there are no words to convey my shock
and sadness regarding the tragic
accident that took the life of helena
hutchins a wife mother and deeply
admired colleague of ours i'm fully
cooperating with the police
investigation to address how this
tragedy occurred and i am in touch with
her husband offering my support to him
and his family my heart is broken for
her husband their son and all who knew
and loved helena it's a crazy situation
it really is let me see if i can get us
as we wait
an additional stream of the
press
uh
briefing
briefing
live
uh
is the washington post ah yes
here we go
all right good so we can keep an eye on
what's going on there
as we stand by
david add more music to your show
yeah i mean i like you just wanna like
music playing in the background i'm not
sure about that i'm not sure if that's
i just don't know about that tristan
says work with a doctor actually means
make the doctor agree that her feelings
are of equal and greater validity than
medical fact yeah that's what she wanted
david says what's up with labeling trump
voters as trumpists they're not
second-class citizens should elite
pretentious liberals be known as
pac-maniacs stop belittling those who
vote differently than you no
it wouldn't make sense to call liberals
pacmaniacs because they didn't vote for
me if you vote for trump
trump is this a plausible name
um this user seems very confused but i
appreciate you spending ten dollars to
say that that that i appreciate
but it does not seem analogous to me
as we wait let's listen to a few
voicemails
let's see what we've got here
um we always try to to do a couple
since we're i'm always so far behind on
voicemails and i know we get a lot of
the same callers let's take a listen
hi dave my name's chris i'm out of
seattle i love your show man
texas has learned about the kids down
there
since they got that open carried law
why don't they just let the kids open
carry in school yeah there's an idea
uh hi david
uh just a a quick comment
um
in regard to
the another facebook interview goes
horribly wrong uh video
um
one thing that i think is interesting to
note is for instance in this interview
the the facebook representative uh the
woman that that's interviewed
okay i'm sorry i'm gonna bail because it
goes the full three minutes and i'm
looking at the transcript and the guy
never actually gets to the point
hey there david um i just noticed by
looking on my membership account that
i'm approaching one year of membership
soon
so i just wanted to say thank you so
much um for all that you and staff are
doing there at the show wow um it's been
really fantastic to listen to i've
become a lot more politically aware than
i ever have been before wow um so i just
wanted to say thank you so much and also
i wanted to say i wanted to personally
present
the bonus show and award of being my
favorite bonus show of all time
so thank you so much wow what a nice
message that's a beautiful message
wholesome
with peace and love
hi david i just wanted to let you know
that i really enjoy your show i just
heard today that you were saying that
most of your voicemails or a lot of them
aren't nice and so i wanted you to have
another nice one i look forward to your
show every day and sometimes it's the
most entertaining
part of my day you make me laugh and
think and i just really appreciate your
humor and your intelligence thank you
wow what we that there can't possibly be
three good ones in a row right let's
listen
hey david my name is stephen i'm from
kansas city missouri i've been watching
your youtube channel for the last four
years and i'm a member
wow frankly you've probably got this
question before um
but if you were not if you didn't pursue
a career in politics all those years ago
where would you see yourself now
um
in a non-politic non-political um type
of job just yeah kind of curious so yeah
probably in texas
um i would almost certainly be working
in tech i think
hi um hello um
david
um
my name is um
titiana
um
i'm sorry i'm a little nervous about
leaving a message
but anyway thank you so much for what
you do and uh
thank you
so
i've been following
oh you know what i'm seeing that uh this
goes three minutes and she doesn't get
to the question but keeps saying she's
nervous so i'm gonna move on because
there's not actually
um
anything that's
asked
as i was saying and so rudely
interrupted
dr john campbell who's a phd in nursing
uh
teach
nursing
actually john campbell has a phd in
philosophy i don't know if he has a phd
in nursing uh he's got youtube channel
he reported on kovid from day one on
let me bring this up too the mere fact
that none of these people that are
poking people giving them a jab
have used uh
the the the method of you draw back a
little bit before you push in the
plunger
to check to see that you're not
injecting into a blood vein yeah that
applies to all vaccination that's
something that's been discussed before
hey dave this is wait um so i was
calling because i saw the benjamin
shapiro show and i was wondering about
what your take on
the
um turkish support
i don't know anything about that i do
want to say thank you to lord labrand as
well as rind
both of whom just grabbed twitch prime
subscriptions numbers 26 and 27 very
much appreciate that today also an extra
special thank you this is a really
really big deal
i want to say thank you to
luis solis
for signing up on my website using the
coupon code sinks and showers we're
looking very strongly at sinks and
showers that's today's coupon code i
would love it if you used it it's a
today only thing luis just did at
joinpackman.com
very much appreciate it few other super
chats here david whackman sending
another five bucks says in order to be a
pacmaniac you need three graduate
degrees and a seven figure net worth you
people are not relatable to the average
working class okay
robert says hollywood perpetuates gun
culture as much as any republican to me
this is as much as any republican to me
this is like a shooting at the nra and
this movie rust glorified gun violence
many hollywood movies glorify gun
violence for sure
brendan asked david would you talk to
shuwon head it would generate good memes
sure
any time
joseph says hey david i took a balance
of nature gummy yesterday
uh went to the bathroom and had to flush
almost 10-15 times god bless and god
bless
the united states
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times right no those are all really
really good points actually
david you're brilliant i would like to
see music integrated into your show it
is the antidote to our woes thank you
for wonderful work love richard joseph
all right here's a song
and then they did dumps they call them
dumps big massive dumps
in michigan and pennsylvania
[Music]
[Music]
okay
and then they did dumps they call them
dumps big massive dumps
uh in michigan and pennsylvania
okay anyway all right let's get back to
what we're doing here um more more
voicemails coming in
i have a joke
okay so i went to a different country
and i couldn't get back on the plane
because the stewardess asked me
if i had cold feet
and i said yes
and i
turned that i didn't have the code that
i had coffee
wow that's uh that's something
hey what's going on david my name is
daryl i live in connecticut um long-time
listener kind of a newer subscriber i
just want to call and say thank you for
all that you do
so many times i see
a trend whether it be talking points or
you know sound bites or or political
advertisements campaign advertisements
where
or even just observations about human
conduct around issues in our country
and
immediately like as i'm coming to
thoughts with this stuff
usually i will find it fully fleshed out
in your program wow as almost in my own
words
um
anyway you you really help
me to
to be prepared for arguments
you know i consider you a a tool in my
tool belt
in a positive sense very nice i very
much appreciate that
did you notice that tesla uh followed
benjamin out to texas like right after
he moved to texas
um
tesla moved his
uh
like company or whatever that was in
california
yep that happened hi david i'm calling
from colorado and i love your show
um i just wanted to know if you know of
any other states that are giving out
rewards and gift cards for the students
to get
tested once a week at the schools i am
not aware of that one way or the other
quite frankly
so um
one of the problems i'm having with like
understanding like
a line of
um
morals or ethics
that one's a little too mumbly
a little too mumbly for me
best pacman greetings from the state of
north carolina
just had to respond to you today
um october 13th
uh
captain kirk went to space yes in basis
rocket and he came back
a very humbled man
which i would imagine when you break
earth's atmosphere
and you get to see the fragility
from
space of this little blue ball
in the middle of a vast black vacuum
it should change you
right
very very important statement
when i start giving across
the message
with evidence
that these people
the doctors
and the [ __ ] police force
all right continuing on hello david uh
this is tom and i've been uh i've been
watching you for quite a while um
i myself not uh
although i'm super interested in
politics i've never voted
but the reason i've never voted is i
never felt
like i was
qualified to
and i just was always curious about your
thoughts on that because
you know
i'm someone who considers myself fairly
politically neutral obviously i listen
to you i listen to people like ben
shapiro on the right
um
and obviously i would consider you guys
to have forgotten more about politics
than i'll never know but then if you
actually speak to people in the general
public
the
i would consider myself very educated
politically compared to other people in
the general public and i'm just kind of
curious yeah this is the problem you
know
smarter more educated more informed
people are generally more aware about
the limits of their knowledge that's
actually a phenomena it's almost like a
moral hazard sort of thing so that's not
a surprise to me that's not a surprise
to me but this this person sounds more
than qualified uh to be voting i want to
say thanks to aj 4a you for signing up
via twitch prime remember if you have
amazon prime
and you're not subscribing to someone
via twitch prime every month you're
leaving money in jeff bezos's pocket
so i'm not saying
use the subscription on my twitch
channel i'm just saying use the
subscription every month because
otherwise you're just leaving your bezos
bucks in jeff bezos's pocket which is
crazy
which is crazy
also
huge thank you to kim haley who just
signed up on my website joinpackman.com
damien lakeda
who just signed up on my website
and josh g who just signed up on my
website numbers 30 31 and 32
using today's coupon code sinks and
showers we're looking very strongly at
sinks and showers very much appreciate
that
um
[Music]
few other super chats a is for aliens
says where did the natural immunity
thing come from why is it such a talking
point is it a lack of understanding of
viruses in general i don't know the or
it's very widespread now but i don't
know the origin of it
probably multi-origin
venom says love your sense of humor
bringing this to us keep kicking ass
thanks venom d block says david you're
awesome you tell it like it is more
shows should be like yours thank you
appreciate that very much
couple other voicemails
let's take a listen to
i don't know this one
hey david
david california
am i the only one that thinks
that if we don't hold the house
in 2022
and trump decides to run for the
presidency
there's a good chance he's going to get
elected
yeah i i yes you're not the only one
that thinks that i've probably done uh
five segments on that
how i saw lesbians act in society like i
don't understand how they would ever get
rights all right and we're gonna get
we're gonna nope right out of that one
hey david great show uh charlie from
connecticut 64 years old
hey uh connecticut's had uh 400 deaths
uh since uh the rest of the country has
had like 115 000.
uh that's less than the crossover cases
that people have been vaccinated and
south south dakota caught up to us uh
since the election uh
if you do the per kappa and uh
certainly uh be cool to explain how
florida and texas caught up to uh new
york yes we i have talked about that
it's actually initially
the the virus was worse in places that
were you know unlucky
to have direct flights to the places the
virus came from
eventually policy is what has determined
how places do and uh it's not looking
very good in most red states that's for
sure i want to say thank you to kenji
nakata who just signed up on my website
joinpakman.com using the coupon code
sinks and showers new member number 33
today also thank you to
hashish
alph mc wet
guitar goddess
dj glen wraps and pukelberry oh god
all of whom signed up via twitch prime
putting us at 38 very much appreciate
that
very powerfully youtubing with david for
two years says leica
thank you
beetle greg says david sir is it true
you will wear a dress when you hit 2
million subscribers i've never mentioned
that
i'm not
totally opposed to it but you know
there's a funny thing about this whole
like i'll wear a dress if thing
because it's like it could really be
interpreted in two ways
it could be like listen
i am just so indifferent to what people
want to wear or you know the sort of
gender norms around clothing that like
sure i'll wear a dress who cares wow
what an enlightened progressive thing to
do the other side would be
the fact that it would that you think it
would be notable to wear a dress shows
actually how stuck up you are or or or
no not stuck up it's how how sort of
like stuck on
it being why is it why would it even be
notable that you wear it you know it's
like it's just so stupid because you
could take either perspective on it um
and quite frankly i'm bored by both
i'm bored by both
so i feel like if science had more
people on its side that science would be
better right and i think that like a lot
of people want to like deny science yep
science needs more advocates i agree
with that that's that's definite
um
here's a full three-minute voicemail
from rhode island that's always risky
let's listen
now david this is d tree from rhode
island yeah so
when you listen to all these crazy
people which not understanding
is that
it's layers of reality whether it's the
physical
emotional mental right and the etheric
in between the buff or that auric level
right but what you're not understanding
is when like these crazy people say
people voted for 600 years old 800 years
old what they mean is this literal group
you know like illuminati was a real
group and told oh stop and they did come
on
i am not fully understanding that but i
do appreciate the call
so i actually stumbled upon some
information about that
and i thought that um people were like
making the most amount of profit oh
boy
mr pac-man
or pac-man is troll man the
anti-intellectual
don't you find it curious
that the vaccines that are being pushed
are the ones that were manufactured by
pharmaceutical companies that are
actually making them for profit
every vaccine that's approved in the u.s
is from a for-profit company so no when
all of the ones that were that submitted
for approval were from for-profit
companies it doesn't surprise me that
the ones that are now
being offered are from for-prof profit
companies just you know just curious i
got it okay
okay so what if i was to live my life by
police rules right that's a really good
question i want to say thank you to
britster12 and r.m page 56
for supporting the stream via twitch
prime numbers 39 and 40. also big thank
you to daniel walker daniel just signed
up on my website joinedpakman.com using
the coupon code sinks and showers we're
looking very strongly at sinks and
showers very much appreciate that
uh do i think steve bannon is hoping to
get arrested to excite the maga base it
wouldn't i wouldn't put it past steve
bannon to be totally honest i would not
put it past steve bannon
dara sum asks where's the biden stream
from yesterday we pulled the recording
for copyright purposes i mentioned it
earlier um we pulled it for those
reasons
alas velas has tweeted voicemailed crew
breakdown for baldwin issue
tweeted voicemailed crew breakdown for
baldwin issue i don't know what that
means
anybody know what that means
whoa
all right looks like things are about to
get going here
um
a couple more voicemails
so i'm really having like a huge issue
with therapy
because of what like they're allowing to
accept
because like they can say in therapy
like whether they're religious or not
and kind of like into like the moral
belief or connotation of like
uh
um abortion and that kind of thing
yeah that i'm not
sure about
that i'm very much unsure about
hey david regarding the election being
stolen do you think it would be more
effective if journalists ask these
republicans
given the recounts lawsuits and
all right that one unfortunately is
going nowhere
hi sir hey my name is dwayne
my comment is i'd like to have a vaccine
made that takes away all the other
vaccines that are already out there
if you don't believe or want this one
you don't get a benefit of all the other
ones have been developed over the last
hundred plus years yeah that would be
interesting i mean imagine if if there
was an announcement made that anybody
who any if you really are committed to
you do not want vaccines
um but growing up you got vaccines you
can go in and you'll get a shot
and it will
it will remove any vaccine-induced
immunity for anything that you've ever
had how many people would actually go
and do that my guess is it would be not
that many but it would be some and it
would probably lead to a bunch of people
very stupidly dying that's my guess
hi david this is ellen you asked me to
get in touch with you once when i
brought up the fact that why don't we
have
you know tv awards for people that don't
want to get vaccinated
and for people that could work there
that don't want to get vaccinated
um what are your thoughts on this i
don't know a tv ward what does that mean
a tv ward
i i just don't know what that means
i apologize
i want to say thanks to rumpus parable
and the loser trumpers for subscribing
via twitch prime putting us at 43
very generously captain dad bod has
gifted five subscriptions via twitch
putting us at 48
and then also dropping in is maria avila
who just signed up at joinpackman.com
using the code sinks and showers putting
us at 49.
let me do what we did at the very start
of this the 50th member counts as five
on my website 50th member counts as five
i'll keep an eye on it here's jen saki
okay
uh just an overview of the week ahead uh
for all of you
um throughout the week uh the president
will continue to meet and call members
of congress about his transformative
build back better agenda and bipartisan
infrastructure deal on monday he will
travel to new jersey where he will visit
a school and one of the busiest railroad
bridges in the country to continue
rallying support for both his bipartisan
infrastructure deal and build back
better agenda back in washington uh
president biden will meet with his
all-holiness ecumenical patriarch
bartholomew and welcome the official
delegation of the orthodox christian
church the united states i was about to
lose my greek american card there for a
second but i think i sailed through on
tuesday the president will campaign with
former governor terry mcauliffe in
arlington virginia we're going to be
covering the president first lady will
travel to rome italy on friday the
president will visit the vatican city
and have an audience with his holiness
pope francis wow they will discuss
working together on efforts grounded in
respect for fundamental human dignity
including ending a covet-19 pandemic
tackling the climate crisis and caring
for the poor on saturday and sunday the
president will participate in the g20
leader summit we will have more on
individual bilateral engagements in the
run-up to the summit and from rome the
president will travel to glasgow united
kingdom from november 1st through the
2nd to participate in the world leader
summit at the start of cop 26 the 26th
conference of the parties to the un
framework convention on climate change i
will note a programming note for all of
you we will have um jake sullivan in
here next week we're working on
finalizing the details to preview the
the trip um in advance of the
president's departure but steve why
don't you kick us off there we go oh
sorry can i know one more thing i
apologize uh today the vice president uh
visited northeast the northeast bronx
ymca new york with hhs hhs secretary
javier becerra governor kathy hokel and
congressman jamal bowman the vice
president will hear about the ymca
facilities impact on the community and
deliver remarks about how the bipartisan
infrastructure deal and the build back
better agenda will benefit working
families she'll also highlight the
importance of extending the child tax
credit which is one of the largest ever
single tax cuts for families with
children okay zeke go ahead big agenda
assess the negotiations over the uh the
president's spending bill um uh
housekeeping supposed to suggest all
right let's switch to a feed where we
can see the reporters okay see go ahead
okay so what's the status the
negotiations over the uh the president's
spending bill uh passenger nancy pelosi
suggested a deal with the united states
expect that and who's he speaking with
right now
well he will continue to have calls uh
throughout the course of the day and the
weekend um as he has over the last
several days we will provide you details
on those as we can
we have a goal as speaker pelosi
conveyed we have milestones and we're
working on finalizing an agreement
that's the status
our focus is on making significant
progress on that we've seen that happen
over the last several days we're
encouraged by the shared commitment to
get this done and deliver for the
american people but i don't have any new
deadlines or timelines uh from here nor
have we set them from here over the last
several days or weeks
that the president proposed initially at
roughly three and a half trillion
the president say he wants to come back
at things later things like uh community
college and the other extending the life
of some of these programs that have been
shortened
um progressives have been saying that
now's the moment to be obeyed there
might not be another moment why does the
president think given how difficult
things have been up to this point that
he'll have another bite at the apple um
to sort of make these programs more
enduring he probably won't even things
that couldn't make it into this body
sometimes
well let me say first zeke that this is
uh this package is on track to be uh to
represent or to direct the most
fundamental shift in supporting
hard-working families over wealthy in
modern american history uh so uh and the
president's belief as you heard him say
last night is that compromise is not a
dirty word and that we will get nothing
if we do not have 50 votes the
alternative is not a larger package the
alternative is nothing so his objective
is to
continue to press forward to bring the
parties together to get a historic
package done and i will note that
there's a lot of history for this and he
talked about this a little bit last
night but there's history in setting
putting in place a framework that puts
in place positive fundamental change
look at social security look at the
affordable care act these are all
historic programs that have then been
built on domestically and whatever the
top line number is which we're still
obviously working through and
negotiating this is on track to change
millions of middle class families who
have been falling behind let me give you
just a couple of examples and he talked
about this last night but where the
package stands as of now the largest
investment in child care and early
education truly childhood education in
history with the first national
universal preschool program ever in
history the largest investment in
climate clean energy in history around
six times the size of the climate and
clean energy investment in the recovery
act the second largest climate bill in
history the first national paid lead
paid family and medical leave program
ever the largest expansion in health
care coverage since the affordable care
act leading seven million people to gain
new coverage perpetuating the largest
one-year drop in child poverty in
history by extending the child tax
credit and a new investment in housing
that is greater than the entire current
annual budget of the department of
housing and urban development that is
what we were talking about here as we
even as we were talking about a package
that's being negotiated that is smaller
than what he originally proposed why
does he think that who thinks their will
versus won't be a question about alec
baldwin at the press briefing here now
uh in getting more spending for some of
those programs at the levels that he
initially wanted that exactly
well two reasons zeke one is what i
referenced related to the social
security program in history or the
affordable care act where these are
programs that put in place uh the
fundamental mechanisms in society to
deliver on change and relief to people
for decades to come and what we're
talking about here is instituting some
programs that have never existed before
universal pre-k we're talking about paid
family and medical leave we're building
on as an example of the affordable care
act by continuing to expand health care
coverage which is another example of
building so the president's belief is
these changes are long overdue these
changes are changes the american people
are have been asking for have been
demanding want to see government act on
to make their lives better and that this
package these packages will be the basis
for building on in the future during his
administration as well
good thanks jen
the president was pretty clear last
night that senator cinema does not
support raising taxes on big
corporations or the corporate tax hike
the white house says that you guys are
looking for other ways to pay for this
package what exactly are those proposals
and can this package be paid for without
a corporate tax increase
yes absolutely but there are different
corporate tax increases in here so let
me go through what a couple of the tax
pieces are that are under consideration
i would note that as it relates to the
president's comments last night he was
answering a question these town halls
are conversations that's what's so
endearing and engaging about them but he
was referring to the challenge of having
the votes to move forward on raising the
corporate rate uh not the ability to
raise revenue through a range of other
tax fairness proposals so let me give
you a sense of a couple of those so some
of the biggest corporations in america
pay literally nothing in income taxes as
we know as we've talked about
in the past a lot in here 55 of the
biggest companies
they pay lower rates than wage earning
families we can stop that by imposing a
15 percent minimum tax a minimum
corporate tax uh to make sure large
corporations pay their fair share we
also believe the president believes a
number of other members of congress
believe that we need to stop rewarding
companies that offshore profits uh and
american jobs uh we'll do that by
creating a global minimum tax something
the united states has been the global
leader in bringing together countries
around the world and that will help to
make the united states more competitive
and end the race to the bottom we can
also close loopholes for high-income
americans including a loophole that
allows some taxpayers like hedge fund
managers to escape a medicare tax
imposed on all high-end income
on all high income that's another
proposal that's out there still and we
can crack down on wealthy tax cheats who
are taking advantage of every honest
taxpayer and invest in enforcement to
stop one percent from evading 160
billion dollars in taxes per year
something that treasury secretaries
republican and democrats have expressed
support for and feel this is a strong
part of the proposal so i list all of
those because those are all ideas out
there all ideas that would move us
forward toward a greater system of tax
fairness and also can help pay uh for
the full package one more follow-up on
the child tax credit uh speaker pelosi
told me uh yesterday that the president
was looking at a one-year extension
according to the census bureau 40 47
percent of families use that money to
buy food
will those children be left behind if
there's only a one-year extension on the
child tax credit yeah it should be clear
the president proposed a longer
extension what the president is though
looking to do is to extend the child tax
credit something that he proposed
himself earlier this year and again
proposed
extending it because he thinks it does
have such an important and dramatic
impact on people across the country many
economists have credited with cutting
the childhood poverty rate in half he
absolutely thinks it should be a part of
what american families can benefit from
but it's smaller because compromise is
not a dirty word
and it is something that we still
believe is a positive step forward to
extend glenn what drove the shift in the
president's posture this week in terms
of he laid out a lot of details to rank
and file members on tuesday he laid out
a lot of details to the entire world
last night uh something you guys haven't
been wanting to talk about over the
course of the last several months why
now why has he moved in this direction
the charm of anderson cooper i guess
just kidding um look i think phil that
we are at this point uh in the
conversation and in the debate where we
are getting into the nitty gritty
details and the president is deeply
engaged in those discussions uh i think
what you saw last night with the
american people saw last night is that
the president has rolled up his sleeves
and he is deep in the details of
spreadsheets and numbers and what the
potential impact can be to help the
american people and
he's he was candid and he was candid
about where the negotiations stood and
also wanted the american people to
understand as i just outlined earlier
that progress here is a historic package
that will put in places
for programs that have never existed in
our society before so i think what
you're seeing is that we're getting
closer we're into the nitty-gritty
details there is agreement about some
fundamental investments in our society
and uh he loves having conversations
with the american people about what he's
fighting for
two more just to follow up on
last night's do more questions
are if they exist at all in terms of the
national guard and the supply chain
oh can we clarify where things stand my
understanding has been talked about but
it wasn't something you guys were moving
toward the president seemed to say
differently last time sure well any
president has the ability to uh to
use the national guard uh from the
federal level uh requesting the use of
the national guard at the state level
which is often how it's done is under
the purview of governors um and we're
not actively asking them to do that and
we're not asked to actively pursuing the
use of the national guard on a federal
level but it is something that any
president would have the capacity to do
the authority to do but it is not
something under active consideration and
then one more um the president was asked
if the u.s would come to taiwan's
defensive attack by china and said yes
we have a commitment to do that is there
a shift in u.s policy as it relates to
taiwan and the defense agreement
uh well there has been no shift the
president was not announcing any change
in our policy nor has he made a decision
to change our policy
there is no change in our policy our
defense relationship with taiwan is
guided by the taiwan relations act some
of the principles of the taiwan
relations act that the united states
will continue to abide by of course is
assisting taiwan and maintaining a
sufficient self-defense by the way
everybody furious with me and chad about
an historic this is an ongoing joke and
apparently both are appropriate
depending on how it's pronounced it's
just it's it's just a grammatical
curiosity everybody relax note that uh
secretary austin also spoke to this
don't cancel here today uh and he said
as the secretary of defense of course
nobody wants to see cross-strait issues
come to blows certainly not president
biden and there's no reason that it
should and that is certainly emblematic
of our approach as well go ahead jeff um
piggybacking on that question about
taiwan the the u.s policy is one of
strategic ambiguity on this
he seemed pretty unambiguous with what
he said last night was that intentional
uh what what i can convey to you is that
our policy has not changed uh he was not
intending to convey a change in policy
nor has he made a decision to change our
policy
moving back to the legislation is the
president confident or is he hoping for
a vote on this before he heads to europe
next week
well his preference would certainly be
to get something done in the coming days
and obviously he will work closely with
speaker pelosi and leader schumer to do
exactly that but i don't have any new
deadlines or timelines to set for you
today beyond citing the rhodium report
if he arrives in glasgow without this in
hand what does he what is his message to
world leaders on that world stage
his message is that he is a president
who will bring the climate crisis back
to the top of the priority list for the
united states and he has already taken
steps to do exactly that not just by
rejoining the paris climate agreement
but by taking steps working with the
leaders of the auto industry to move
towards electric vehicles and electric
vehicle future to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions here in the united states and
that he has proposed the largest
investment in addressing the climate
crisis in american history uh and that
is something we are on track to deliver
on even with a smaller package
lastly is the president or the white
house have a reaction to the alec
baldwin
there it is
other than to say that is obviously a
tragedy the loss of life uh and as i
understand it the individual who is in
the hospital and so our our thoughts and
prayers go out to their family members
but no we do beyond that we don't have
an additional u.s reaction thank you jen
and follow on china and taiwan just to
be crystal clear when the president says
that
the u.s has a commitment to protect
taiwan does that commitment include
military intervention
in the event of a chinese attack
uh again as i said earlier he wasn't
announcing a change in policy nor was he
nor have we changed our policy which i
think is the most important point here
and we are guided by the taiwan
relations act and i just outlined what
some of those principles are which is
ensuring that uh we continue to assist
taiwan and maintaining a sufficient self
self-defense capability and that is
something we remain committed to doing
so can you just remind us that policy is
no there would not be military
intervention right our policy is to be
guided by the taiwan relations act which
is the specifics of that or that we are
going to continue assisting taiwan in
maintaining a sufficient self-defense
capability another principle is that we
regard any effort to determine the
future of taiwan by other than peaceful
means as a threat to the peace and
security of the western pacific but as i
noted earlier our secretary of defense
conveyed clearly what our policy and our
view is which is that no one wants to
see cross-strait issues come to blows
that is what we want to avoid and that's
what the american people should
understand is our focus
that's the view of the president that's
the view of the secretary of defense and
there's no reason anyone should think
otherwise follow up on all those
tax options that you might have if
the corporate tax is not raised and if
there is no uh hike in taxes on the
wealthy well all of those still
guarantee
that this package will not be deficit
spending yes okay and none of that has
been concluded i think i gave all those
additional components of tax options
that are out there that and senator
cinema can obviously speak for herself
as i always convey from here but she has
been supportive of another a number of
these options as have others and those
are all options that can help ensure
we're moving toward a more fair tax
system but also pay for these uh
investments
one more on the filibuster
um
what are some ways that the filibuster
can be fundamentally altered without
ending it all together
look i think the president will have
more to say about this in the coming
weeks but i think what you heard him say
last night is that
we're at an inflection point uh in a
range of it on a range of issues
including and this is often why it comes
up voting rights and he talked about
this a little bit yesterday when he was
at the 10th anniversary of the mlk
memorial we know the right to vote and
the rule of law are under unrelenting
assault from republican governors
attorneys general secretaries of state
state legislators and legislators and
time and time again when offered the
choice three times over the last several
months when a hand has been extended by
democrats to work together to protect
the fundamental right republicans have
not only recoiled they have blocked the
pro the ability to make any semblance of
progress so what the president's
referring to is the fact that that is
unacceptable the protection of a
fundamental the fundamental right to
vote is something that has been
bipartisan in the past he spoke back in
march about uh about his concerns or or
how he would view it if the republicans
continue to be
obstructionist around it and we've seen
that time and time again so he will
discuss what that looks like because not
getting voting rights done is not an
option
does that frustration explain his
evolution
of thinking on the filibuster in july he
said eliminating it would throw congress
into chaos and nothing would get done
well i would also note that back in
march uh he noted that uh if there was
obstruction that it was something that
we would have to take a look at so look
i think people many of you have covered
the president for some time and you know
that uh his view is that we should
pursue ways to work in a bipartisan
manner that we should pursue paths
forward that can get things done for the
american people when he helped
lead the effort to authorize the voting
rights
bill back when he was a senator that was
done in a bipartisan way
and he is frustrated he is disappointed
he is sad
that this is not something that
republicans seem willing to engage on to
work on and i think what you saw
reflected last night is his his view
that in light of the tax on our
democracy
what we've seen across the country and
states and by state legislators that it
is time to have a conversation about
what this looks like moving forward go
ahead thank you jen the leader of the
union representing fedex ups and dhl is
saying that supply chain problems are
going to get worse with labor shortages
right before the holidays unless the
president postpones the requirement to
get vaccinated by december 8th so what
is more important to this what
the vaccine mandates for fixing the
supply chain as fast as possible
well first i would say that that is not
actually what we've seen at companies
that have implemented these vaccine
requirements that are not even part of
federal law yet let me just let me just
finish i'm gonna let you talk don't
worry very rude to interrupt her
constantly american and southwest ceos
have made clear this one their their
work workers will not be there there
won't be a labor shortage we've seen
united airlines implement this and as
we've also said as we work to implement
these federal employee requirements the
first step is not firings it's actually
education and counseling so we don't
actually anticipate these disruptions
what we've seen for companies who have
implemented these requirements is an
increase from 20 to 90 last thing then
i'll let you ask your follow-up is that
the other piece of this is that covid is
an enormous labor disrupter not only
because it's the number one cause of
death in some industries and some
professions including police forces
across the country but because people
are out sick people are worried about
coming to work this is one of the
reasons that a lot of these companies
have implemented these requirements just
so that i understand the position then
this union leader says that the looming
december 8th mandate for having fully
vaccinated workforces like who is this
significant supply chain problem you say
no it does not that's one guy's opinion
what i would point to peter is the uh
evidence we've seen from companies of
large companies private sector companies
that have implemented these requirements
across the board okay following up on
something else the president said last
night why did president biden say he has
been to the border
well peter
as you may have seen there's been a
reporting that he
did drive through the border when he was
on the campaign trail in 2008 and he is
certainly familiar with the fact and it
stuck with him with the fact that uh in
el paso the border goes right through
the center of town but what the most
important thing everyone should know and
understand is that the president has
worked on these issues it's now a
referendum on whether he really got
close enough to the border for it to
count her immigration system including
the border that includes when he was
vice president and he went to mexico and
central america 10 times to address
border issues and talk about what we can
do to reduce the number of migrants who
are coming to the border he worked in a
bipartisan manner with senators like ted
kennedy harry reid john mccain and
others to push for comprehensive fine
but did he make xenophobic comment while
he was at the border gen border to know
what a mess was left by the last
administration that's his view does that
count as a visit he said i've been there
before you're saying he drove by for a
few minutes does that count
what do you what is the root cause where
are people coming from who are coming to
the border peter the president said i'm
asking you i'm asking you a question
because i think people should understand
the context where do people where do
people come i'm asking you okay i'll
answer it for you people come from
central america and mexico to go to the
border the president has been to those
countries 10 times to talk about border
issues there is a focus right now on a
photo op the president does not believe
a photo op is the same as solutions
that may be a difference he has with
republicans but that's not what he said
either he said i guess i should go down
so does he think that he needs a photo
op is that what he's saying he doesn't
and that's a fundamental disagreement he
has i would say the former president
went to the border at least once maybe
more you may know the numbers
how did that immigration policy result
peter that immigration policy resulted
in separating kids from their parents
building a border wall that's feckless
and that cost
dollars for taxpayers president
fundamentally disagrees on how we need
to approach the immigration anything
changed at the border between 2008 when
he drove by in 2021
aside from the fact that migrants are
still coming to the border through the
course of democratic and republican
presidents and the uh the immigrant the
need to reform the immigration system is
even farther long overdue no but we need
to work with democrats and republicans
to get that done i think we're gonna
have to keep chugging along here go
ahead let me ask you if i can about gas
prices the president was asked about
that a lot of americans have been
concerned about the cost to go to the
pump these days he said i don't see
anything that's going to happen in the
meantime that's going to significantly
reduce gas prices he said i don't have a
near-term
answer for americans who are looking for
an answer what is the answer well what
is true and i think the president as we
as i said earlier was quite candid last
night as the american people should
express from him uh expect from him and
from any president um and there are
limitations to what any president can do
do you think peter ducey thinks that
that was really strong by him we are
engaging broadly with opec on our
concerns at a range of levels
and that is something we will continue
to do as you know jake sullivan our
national security advisor recently met
with leaders in saudi arabia and
certainly raised this issue the
president has also been concerned as the
administration has been about what we
have seen as
rises in supply that have not been
accompanied by drops in cost that's one
of the reasons he's asked the ftc to
look into price gouging something that
is no doubt impacting or we expect might
be impacting the cost of gas around the
country so we are working and using
every single lever he can but i think
what people heard from him is some
candor about what impacts we can have he
amused that he could go into the
strategic petroleum reserve and that
could bring the cost down he said it
would still be above three dollars will
he do that i don't have anything to
preview on that front at this point let
me ask does the white house have any
response to the supreme court today
saying that it's not going to block the
texas abortion ban although it did grant
an expedited review to take place uh i
think by the start of november well uh i
would naturally defer any particular
questions about the supreme court
decision and litigation to the
department of justice but what i can
reiterate is that the president has been
clear in his position that sb-8 is
blatantly unconstitutional not only
violates the right to safe and legal
abortion established under roe v wade
but it creates a scheme to allow private
citizens to interfere with that right
and to evade judicial review that is why
he's directed a whole government
response to it and why he will continue
to stand side by side with women across
the country to protect their rights but
in terms of any litigation steps i'd
point to the prime of justice
contingencies at the supreme court
is to uphold that present ban what
contingencies what process takes place
behind closed doors here at the white
house to help look out for the women in
that state again as you know the gender
policy council and leaders there are
leading the effort to work and see what
levers in government we can use uh to
continue to protect women's fundamental
rights uh we will see if there's an
update on that to provide to all of you
go ahead and study i'll continue thank
you the attack on a military outpost in
southern syria this week did not result
in any american casualties but the u.s
military considers it to be a serious
but failed attempt to take american
lives do you know who's responsible and
what is the administration doing to
prevent another attack or hold the
perpetrators accountable
um
i don't have any updates for you on the
um on the responsibility um and of
course what happened uh is something
that is great concern to us i have
nothing to preview in terms of what
additional steps will be
some governments including u.s partners
in the region have moved toward
normalizing relations with the assad
regime has the administration directly
urges counterparts against doing so
nothing has changed about the u.s
position as it relates to the assad
regime in terms of private diplomatic
conversations i'd point to the state
department lastly because you know there
was a broader review of sanctions policy
by the treasury department that was
released this week it stated sanctions
are most effective on a multilateral
basis so if other countries including
u.s partners are resuming diplomatic and
commercial ties with syria does it not
undermine u.s sanctions and what does
the administration plan to do about it
under say that last part one more time
not undermine u.s sanctions if other
partners are resuming diplomatic and
commercial ties with the assad regime is
there anything the administration plans
to do about that uh i don't have
anything to preview for you at this
point in time i again would point you to
the state department our view of the
assad regime has not changed i would
note on the attack which you asked me
about let me give you all a little bit
more context on that
u.s central command confirmed last night
and put out a statement or maybe it was
earlier sorry uh that uh the uh the uh
alton garrison area was subjected to a
deliberate and coordinated attack uh
initial reports uh indicate both
unmanned aerial systems and rockets were
used in the attack all u.s personnel
have been accounted for we're not aware
of any injuries to us personnel at this
time of course we always reserve the
right to respond as i noted we have
nothing to preview on that front and
we're still investigating but
regarding kids in vaccines a new poll is
talking about two-thirds of parents with
kids between 5 and 11. they're having a
wait-and-see attitude or they're
resisting it all together and so what is
the white house doing to combat that
vaccine presidency amongst parents well
first i would note that we have
experienced this before because if you
look back to december only about 30
percent or just over that of people who
are eligible for vaccines said they
would want to take a vaccine and now
we're at nearly 80 percent of eligible
uh adults or people who are out of the
eligible age who have now received their
first dose
we have launched and we announced the
launch last week or our intention to
launch a major campaign to communicate
with parents to communicate with
families about the safety and the
efficacy of these vaccines should they
get approval we will also be prepared to
have the doses needed to ensure that
parents it's funny how at their core a
lot of these questions are like how do
we deal with the fact that so many
people are so stupid like the peter
ducey question about the board of the
board of border really is how do we deal
with the fact that so many people
stupidly think that if when and how
close biden got to the border physically
has any bearing on immigration policy
here it's how do we deal with the fact
that we still have so many ignorant
people who refuse to get vaccinated at
their core so many questions are really
about stupid people true question when
is something about the moscow conference
the united states was not able to
participate it what was the reason
number two nato conference any result
and number three so many afghan people
especially women they are under torture
of the taliban and they have high
expectations from the united states and
i don't know you guys still
committed to help afghan people or
united states totally forget afghan
people
absolutely not on the last piece we
remain absolutely committed to
helping the afghan people we remain the
largest provider of humanitarian
assistance of any country in the world
and we're committed to ensuring there is
the ability for people who want to leave
to depart ensuring there are flights
that can depart to do that or people can
cross over land and continue to work
with
relied on reliable
international organizations like the
world food program to provide that
assistance in terms of the nato
conference i know our secretary of
defense spoke to that i'd point you to
his comments and his press conference on
the ground and on your first question i
know my colleague at the state
department ned price said that the
united states supported the talks we
were unable to attend for logistical
reasons we believe the troika plus which
is what this forum or format is has been
an effective and constructive forum we
look forward to engaging that forum
going forward uh but we weren't in a
position to be a part of it this week uh
but we will in the future go ahead
thank you i i wanted to clarify you've
been you know earlier at the at the
start of this you talked about how
universal pre-k family leave are those
things that will definitely be in the
bill because you're saying no matter
what happens it looks like we'll have at
least as much so i was just wondering
can you clarify is that are those things
definitely going to be in there are
those red lines for the the president
i'm not here to set new red lines what
we know is that this is going to be the
most historic investment in child care
and care in the care economy
ever in history and that there will be
programs put in place that have not
existed in the past
hopefully we will know more soon what
the final package looks like but i just
wanted to outline some of the key
components that there's continued
discussion about i know you didn't
mention medicare expansion in that it's
like is that intentional like why it was
not intentional i was trying to give a
couple of
i was trying to give a couple of
examples because sometimes
we we miss the historic comparison here
on what we're talking about and what
kind of a dramatic impact this package
will have on families across the country
and what it's tracking to be there are
still final pieces that need to be
concluded and i can't give you a final
fact sheet quite yet um but that's what
i wanted to lay out for all of you
another quick question does the white
house have any thoughts on the supreme
court yes they're taking up the texas uh
the the texas abortion law but they're
not going to rule on the
constitutionality of it does the white
house have any thoughts on it i would be
on what i said to peter i don't have
anything additional from here i
appointed the department of justice
good thank you jen um just to follow up
on the medicare expansion do you have
any updates
president biden addressed some of these
discussions
last night
and whether this will be an actual
expansion or vouchers for things
such as dental work
is there any update in those discussions
not yet um he talked a little bit for
those of you who didn't watch the town
hall last night um from 8 to 9 30. um he
talked a little bit about how he wants
to his objective of working to bring
down the cost so i think you're
referring just to translate for
everybody to bring them up he talked a
little bit about the possibility of
vouchers for dental something that's in
discussion but there's no new
information i can provide to all of you
he also talked about
the hearing aids and bringing down the
cost of hearing aids and bringing that
cost down and addressing it for seniors
is a huge priority uh to him he also
mentioned last night how when you look
at seniors and what they're struggling
with including dementia that hearing and
the ability to hear is an important
priority still in discussion clearly a
priority to a number of key leaders in
the senate but there's not a final
conclusion before i came out here today
um
nancy pelosi uh
who i believe had breakfast here uh this
morning she did um she was here i'm not
sure what they ate but uh but they met
so yes uh she indicated that a climate
deal was close
and suggested it could be done
has the white house and congressional
democrats identified any substitute for
the clean energy performance program
that looks to be removed uh at joe
manchin's request and if so what is it
well the the president talked a little
bit last night about the fact that and
and i would say it's still on track uh
to be because there are so many climate
components in these two packages that
the president has proposed including
climate tax credit tax credits and tax
cuts which are have been a part of his
proposal has has broad support uh in the
senate uh they're also key components
since you gave me the opportunity that
have been in the infrastructure plan
that often we don't talk enough about
including
moving toward electric vehicles 500 000
charging stations across the country
which would be a huge impact have a big
impact in moving toward an industry that
would reduce greenhouse gas emissions
replacing lead pipes in water i think
many of you may have seen today that the
state of michigan issued a state of
emergency because of lead-in pipes this
is an area and a place that is a climate
impact it has a humane impact these are
all components that are under discussion
and
obviously the infrastructure pieces have
passed but continue to be a part of what
the president's proposed but addressing
the climate making this the largest
climate bill in history we'll continue
to be on track toward that
the president last night said he would
entertain the notion of doing away with
the filibuster to pass voting rights and
then he added and maybe more what's the
maybe more
nothing to preview it's a habit just to
have a discussion i expect you'll hear
more from the president about it in the
coming weeks go ahead
matt took my climate question but
that's okay
you can ask in a different way okay
on immigration though the president uh
said yesterday that the administration's
stance is that it is opposed to mpp the
remaining mexico policy but there's a
court order and you're implementing that
court order right now but even with that
that court order addressed a previous
memo of the administration to terminate
and yeah it's been months uh since this
court order and there's still no new
memo out and why is that secretary
mayorkas has indicated he plans to issue
a new memo and that we do oppose uh the
mpp program as the president said last
night i would point you the department
of homeland security on an update on the
status
given that he is saying the
administration is opposed and he's
criticized us in the past it seems like
there's not a sense of urgency to to get
this memo out since it's been months i
wouldn't agree with that i think we've
been clear about our opposition to this
but again there was a court order uh so
what we're working to do is move toward
the release of a new uh memorandum
something that would come from the
department of homeland security uh and
while also uh abiding in good faith by a
court order and following the law
afghanistan sure just if given that the
embassy is currently closed right now in
kabul as well if if you're an afghan and
you still are hoping to find relief and
come to the u.s is there any way to
actually get parole or refugee status
without going to a third country well we
have a presence in doha one that engages
uh with a counterpart with uh officials
on the ground we've also had recent
meetings with leaders of the taliban as
you all know and has been reported
publicly and our state department is
leading this effort so yes absolutely
there is we have worked to help uh
individuals who have stood by our side
and fought by our side over the course
of the last uh two months since we left
we ended our military presence there
we've put out i know the state
department put out numbers on u.s
citizens and legal permanent residents
who have departed from kabul we wouldn't
be able to do that unless we had the
diplomatic presence in doha and were
able to engage with and work with
authorities on the ground
last night also the president said that
paid leave was down to four weeks when
he said that did he mean that it would
be a permanent program in that it
wouldn't be sunsetted any time over over
the next decade and did he mean that it
would be four weeks and scale up or just
four weeks flat i think he was conveying
that he had proposed 12 weeks it was
closer to four the specifics of the
details and where that sits right now i
don't have an update for you on okay so
closer to four not necessarily again
francesca he was just speaking to where
things stood last night there's
obviously been ongoing discussions this
morning but uh clearly making sure paid
leave is a is law is a reality for uh
working parents across the country is a
priority that's why he proposed it but
in terms of the exact status i don't
have an update for you on that in this
moment and on free community college yes
that i promise you i guarantee you we're
going to get free community college in
the next several years across the board
so what makes him so certain that he'll
be able to get community college free
community college in the next several
years if it's not going to be included
right now
he's in the first nine months of his
presidency and he knows and understands
as he said last night that uh that
making a community college accessible
than ensuring we have a more educated
workforce out in the country i hope we
get community college done i'm not
optimistic competitiveness and certainly
in the interest of the american people
there's still discussions about how to
make community college more accessible
more affordable these pieces are still
being negotiated i think what you heard
from him or what the american people
heard from him last night uh is not just
his marital obligation but is his
commitment to getting this done because
he thinks it's in the interests of the
united states and our workforce here go
ahead thank you jen thank you i'd like
to ask first about chess access and then
about coronavirus origins
um we as a press corps are fairly
unanimous in our opposition to the
mysterious uh pre-screening process
that's been going on for uh presidential
events in the east room and so i'm
hoping that you can demystify for us how
white house staff are selecting which
journalists get into these events the
first come first serve all right
good question will this pre-screening
remain in place
well we have uh we are still in the
middle of a pandemic as you know uh
people are wearing masks in this room as
a reflection of that we have certain
requirements here as well among staff
and i think we don't have the size of
numbers that we would all like to have
in the east room and we hope that we
make changes to that soon
is that not important that we're going
to expand access and make sure more
people can get into the east wing
but how are the decisions made about who
gets to go in there's a limited number
that we have based on how many how many
people are attending as guests i don't
have any more information on that go
ahead karen i think we're going to move
on go ahead thanks jen has the president
uh spoken to senator's mansion or cinema
cutting that off
i don't have any updates uh on his call
specifically but we have been in regular
touch with them even through the course
of the morning from senior staff you had
said in answer to phil's question that
uh you know the president last night was
focusing on the nitty-gritty details and
that he was candid about where the
negotiations stood he was also much more
candid in pointing out the roadblocks
that senators manchin and cinema have
put up to some of the things he would
like to do and what they're opposed to
did he do that to try and move them
through public pressure or was it to lay
the groundwork for what will be a scaled
back final
deal on this he was simply candidly
answering questions he also referred to
senator cinema as someone who's smart as
the devil
which he has used many times in the past
to describe the vice president to
describe rahm emanuel it's a point of
endearment from him he described senator
manchin as a friend
he believes and continues to believe
that
he is negotiating and working with both
senators in good faith and that we all
are working towards shared objectives so
he was simply answering questions that
were asked by the audience and the
moderator
yeah this follows a little bit on on
that this week has been an interesting
mix of inside game with his
behind-the-scenes talks and outside game
with
scranton and baltimore my question is
whether the time has passed where
speeches can be expected to be effective
in moving any votes i mean
do you think
any member
watched the town hall meeting and said
oh that's going to change my vote
[Laughter]
you know i'm not sure that his audience
was uh he's sort of asking how does
politics work residing in this area in
this area in the zip code right his
audience was uh the american people who
have questions about what this means for
them for child care and how it will help
them
for people who really want to send their
kids to pre-k but can't afford it for
people who are worried about paid leave
and
and hoping that's a reality for them
when they're at the point of having
children or needing to care for loved
ones and so this was really the audience
was really the public and the american
people and the vast majority of
questions came from individuals in the
audience last night
the important thing right now is the
him working his relationships in the
inside game to get the votes
that that is has been important from the
beginning and the president has
obviously played a key role here in
bringing uh different viewpoints
together toward a shared path forward
that's the role that he play has played
as president the role he promised to
play when he ran for president again
running on the fact that compromise is
not a dirty word and he believes he can
bring people together from differing
viewpoints he also believes in a lot of
members will tell you or others this too
that part of his role is talking to the
american public about the benefits of
these packages and explaining to them
beyond sometimes the noise and important
conversation about the mechanisms of
who's forward and against it and the
size and the numbers about how this is
going to help them so last night was an
opportunity to do that
go ahead thank you jen uh my first
question is on the president's climate
agenda so yesterday karen
seems to suggest that should cepp fail
to be included in the reconciliation
bill executive action is an option do i
have that correctly do i understand that
correctly first of all and then second
should his climate agenda fail in
congress whether cpp or other components
can we expect executive action in some
sort of executive order before the
president's trip to europe so that he
may have a stronger message on the
global station climate well i think it's
important to note that some of the
progress the president's made to date
some has been executive action like
rejoining the paris agreement but some
has been simply by working with
leaders
leaders in the
auto industry to bring them together to
agree upon
shared investments in the electric
vehicles industry so there's a lot of
ways that the president will continue to
work use the levers of his power to make
sure we are reaching his bold and
ambitious goals and we've talked a
little bit in here about the rhodium
study from the other day which showed
that there are a lot of different paths
forward to reach those goals some of
them legislative some of them through
actions he can take as president some of
them through working with the private
sector and other other leaders who share
his commitment to getting to addressing
the climate crisis
my second question uh
i didn't i actually don't think that's
the case so i'd
just to be clear
what was your question just to be clear
for the record here action before the
president leaves uh for europe next week
i think what i was giving for you is a
contextual answer on how we're going to
achieve our climate objectives which is
of course what he's going to go to paris
uh at paris we're not going there but
what i mean is like a little i wish um
he uh what he's going to talk about when
he's in glasgow and i think what leaders
will understand is that there are a lot
of paths to get there this is a
president who's committed to addressing
the climate crisis he's taken executive
action he's also brought leaders
together and as you heard him say last
night he's confident that we can get
this passed and get the biggest climate
uh bill passed through congress uh in
the in the near term go ahead i have a
second question jen sorry on um i'm
gonna try this again i know you've
answered the question on taiwan like 10
times already but as you said yourself
words matter so my question is did the
president simply misspoke last night or
was he actually sending a signal that
there may be some sort of informal shift
that the us commitment towards taiwan
may be more firm his policy has not
changed but that's i think important for
people to know and understand go ahead a
quick question follow-up from yesterday
uh your colleague karine said last year
under trump during the holidays families
were facing down a dark winter with less
economic security than ever before but
this year families are facing highest
gas prices in 77 years 30 percent higher
cost to heat their homes inflation that
is almost five times higher than it was
in december groceries are more expensive
so i'm wondering what americans are
facing this thanksgiving and christmas
under president biden when looking at
economic security
well i would say we have cut in half the
unemployment rate created five million
jobs ensured that 180 million americans
have vaccine have been vaccinated since
last year so yes are there still as the
economy is turning back on are there
still fundamental issues we're working
through absolutely that's why the
president is pushing to get his agenda
done but i think there's no question
that a year ago when we were locked in
our homes when one only one percent of
people were vaccinated when 10 of people
in this country were unemployed that was
an incredibly dark time and dark period
in our country go ahead
thanks so much i want to ask you about
public opinion polls which i'm sure you
recognize the president's public opinion
polls have declined sharply over the
last few months and i want to get a
sense from you
in speaking to your white house
colleagues why you think that is i know
you've mentioned kova before but is it
also because of the chaotic withdrawal
from afghanistan is it the stalled
agenda for president biden what do you
suppose is the reason that we've seen
this slide in the president's approval
ratings
well a lot of people in this room work
for organizations that have done polls
and there's a lot of underlying data in
them and sometimes it differs so
i would just go back to what our view is
is that we're still going through a hard
time in this country and people are
tired of fighting a pandemic they're
tired of the impact on their lives some
of them are sick and tired of people who
won't get vaccinated who they feel are
impacting their ability to live life in
a normal way
some people are still fearful for loved
ones and we all thought that it would be
over at this point in time obviously the
delta variant and other factors have led
to this to be extended so there's no
question that the fatigue with covet is
impacting people around the country the
president understands that he's
empathetic to that and he knows that the
best thing he can do is help get coveted
under control continue to work to
address some fundamental issues in our
economy put people back to work and
that's what he's focused on every day
turn things around jen what what's the
way is it just getting victories is it
is it passing the bipartisan
infrastructure bill what's the way that
you think president biden can turn
around these sliding approval ratios he
can keep his keep his head focused on
doing the job doing the job as president
leading the american people
make putting in place fundamental
changes that will make people's lives
better
go ahead shelby thanks uh the dhs
secretary said i think it's just about a
month ago now that the investigation
into the horse that border control
agents would be completed in days not
weeks
um has the white house received any
update on this investigation was there
any conclusion on whether these border
patrol agents were lifting migrants it's
really under the homeland security
department i can check with them and see
what the status is i i know what he said
at the time and i will see if there's
any particular update on that is is the
white house an act of communication with
the dhs on this like do you know why yes
but they're overseeing the investigation
so uh we'll i would point to them on any
update on the status go ahead okay one
more go ahead thanks jen sing what what
we're witnessing happen in haiti right
now along with the threat of the 17
missionaries starting to be killed
is there any conversation within the
administration to
to to stop deportations um that are
happening or using the administration's
power to grant humanitarian parole um
what's being done or even adding u.s
military presence on the ground
so what i think it's important to note
here is obviously we are working around
the clock to bring these people home
they're u.s citizens and there has been
targeting over the course of the last
few years of u.s citizens in haiti and
other countries too it's not the only
country but since we're talking about
haiti and and for kidnapping for ransom
that is one of the reasons that the
state department issued the warning they
did in august about about the risk of
kidnapping for ransom so this is a
little bit of a different category of
individuals in the country and what
they're being targeted for that's why we
issued that warning at the same time
we are continuing to provide
humanitarian assistance to work with
officials on the ground to work through
our embassy to certainly address the
underlying conditions as people in the
country uh attempt to move forward or
tried to recover from a combination of
the earthquake uh and the assassination
of the leader thanks so much
again i think it's important to note
that these individuals were citizen u.s
citizens who were who were targeted it's
so we're working to bring them home
obviously department of homeland
security and state does evaluate any any
conditions before they send people back
to any country as they've done here and
there has been no change thank you
everyone
you too all right so there is the end of
the press briefing um some good
questions some questions that are only
really questions because as i mentioned
earlier there's a lot of dumb people
just kind of floating around and we have
a lot of self-inflicted problems in the
united states as a result of that
but an interesting press briefing
nonetheless
thanks to everybody who joined me i will
be covering live on november 2nd the
virginia gubernatorial election results
very important election day actually
november 2nd a lot's going on there's
mayoral elections around the country and
a lot of important stuff so we'll have
live results that night
sunday
1 p.m eastern 10 a.m pacific i'm playing
in a squid chess tournament organized by
anna kremling a whole bunch of people
are playing i think our friend levy
rosman is going to be on it um i don't
even know it's some kind of competition
32 people i'm going to try to win i
don't even know what's going on but i'm
going to be doing it that's sunday at 1
p.m eastern time that may be twitch only
we'll see
but in any case thank you for joining me
today and we'll be back soon